[Musique]
et pourront débattre nous sommes en
direct avec me nommer garbade chef du
service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière merci bruno mégarde à
naître avec nous à vos côtés bertrand
legrand médecins généralistes bonsoir
bertrand legrand alors moins de 50 % de
personnel soignant on n'est pas de
vacciner alors qu'il était prioritaire
on le rappelle olivier verront le
ministre de la santé tire la sonnette
d'alarmé écoutez je fais vraiment un
appel solennel aux soignants qui n'ont
pas été vaccinés pour qu'il franchisse
le cap c'est important ils ne peuvent
pas être moins vacciner que la
population générale
alors clairement un bruno m'égare ban
faut-il rendre obligatoire cette
vaccination pour les personnes au
contact des plus fragiles selon vos jeux
l'aider il faut d'abord commencer par de
la pédagogie rappelé évidemment
l'importance de la vaccination
le fait que le vaccin protège contre les
formes graves de lakovic 19 et surtout
réduit de façon drastique la
contamination et de ce fait évidemment
tout soignants se doit évidemment de
protéger les patients dont il a la
charge est à mon sens se doit donc de se
faire vacciner si effectivement dans
quelques jours ou semaines
on voit qu'il ya une stagnation du
nombre de soignants vacciner je crois
qu'effectivement il faudra rendre la
vaccination obligatoire il n'est pas
acceptable évidemment que à nouveau en
septembre octobre
lakovic 19 redevienne la premières
causes d'infections nosocomiales à
l'hôpital et entraîne le décès des
personnes les plus fragiles notamment en
ehpad alors bertrand legrand faire de la
pédagogie auprès des personnes
certainement qui sont le plus informé ça
paraît un petit peu bizarre n'est-ce pas
je pense que derrière le chiffre de
soignants ou derrière la le conglomérat
de soignants on range des réalités qui
sont bien différentes et que dans les
catégories de soignants on a des taux de
vaccinations qui sont très différents on
sait que chez par exemple dans les
médecins libéraux
on est à largement plus de 85 % de
personnes vaccinées et que ceux qui sont
pas vaccinés sont en attente de pouvoir
se faire vacciner tout simplement parce
qu'ils ont été contaminés
c'est à peu près la même situation chez
infirmiers et par contre on a une chose
de qui existe et c'est malheureusement
ce que moi je vis aussi dans mon cabinet
les patients les plus défavorisés sont
aussi ceux qui sont le plus rétif à la
vaccination
et je vous rappelle que dans les ehpad
c'est mal payés le travail est difficile
et que nous avons deux dans des
personnels qui sont vraiment entrés en
situation de précarité et donc on est
vraiment dans une population qui est
parfaitement ciblée et c'est une
population qui est rétive à la
vaccination quelle qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs et c'est pas très étonnant ce
chiffre ce qui est très étonnant c'est
l'absence en fait le politiquement
correct de ne jamais dire la réalité des
choses est la vraie a été des choses
c'est que dans les ehpad les gens sont
très mal payés pour un travail très
difficile et comprend des gens avec un
milieu je dirais culturel qui est trop
bas par rapport au travail qu'on leur
demande de faire ça c'est une réalité et
on en arrive à des situations où
effectivement on pourrait se retrouver
comme en belgique ou des situations de
variants delta se développent dans des
ehpad et on connaisse et les situations
dramatiques que ça va porter dont il est
très important de faire de la pédagogie
auprès de ces gens là et la pédagogie
prêter gens là elle passe par leur
médecin traitant et non pas par des
grands centres de vaccination qui sont
trop informel et qui veut dans lequel
n'ont pas assez de confiance et bruno
megaman de choses important dans ce
vient de nous dire bertrand legrand tout
d'abord cet écart entre le personnel
soignant en ehpad et les professionnels
libéraux ans c'est à dire on villes qui
sont davantage vacciner et l'explication
qu'avance le docteur le grand voile à
des personnels peut-être défavorisés
socialement parlant est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette explication ce
diagnostic alors oui effectivement on
note bien un différentiel du taux de
vaccination entre les différents
personnels soignants les médecins à
l'hôpital sont vaccinés pour plus de 90%
al'inverse les aides soignants les
brancardiers le sont à peine à 50 %
malgré tout tout ce personnel quel que
soit son origine sociale quel que soit
son rôle dans la chaîne de soins va être
en contact avec le patient et donc
risque bien sûr de le contaminer il faut
donc évidemment dans un premier temps
user de pédagogie d'explication
j'entends tout à fait bien sûr qu'il lui
faille réexpliqué peut-être certaines
personnel moins susceptibles d'avoir
bien compris les choses
l'intérêt de la vaccination maintenant à
mon sens je dirais même si en provenance
peut-être en d'un milieu social un peu
plus défavorisés on a moins accès à
l'information
il n'y a pas de raison que le fait
d'être moins payés entraîne
l'acceptation d'être non vaccinés a la
base je suis bien sûr tout à fait
d'accord que l'ensemble du personnel
soignant devrait payer la juste hauteur
de son travail et je suis d'accord que
les professions les moins qualifiés sont
très mal payés à l'hôpital pourtant ils
sont indispensables et on a vu qu'avec
la crise ça a été le point clé
évidemment qui a bloqué le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital public
je voudrais vous faire réagir sur la vie
de l'académie de médecine qui semblait
assez raccord avec le ministre de la
santé qui souhaiteraient certainement
rendre obligatoire cette vaccination
écouter la population des soignants est
à l'origine de 34 % des cas groupés
d'infections nosocomiales asra skov 2
considérant que l'hésitation vaccinale
éthiquement inacceptable chez les
soignants l'académie nationale de
médecine recommande de rendre
obligatoire la vaccination contre la
copie de 19 pour tous les professionnels
de santé
bertrand legrand l'hésitation orexine
aller éthiquement inacceptable chez les
soignants il ya un petit côté
moralisateur dans cette sortie de
l'académie de
de médecine qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous en tout cas de cette approche a
tout à fait raison c'est ce que je
rappelle systématiquement au grand
carbet aux aides soignants quand j'en ai
dans mon cabinet on peut pas prendre le
risque de contaminer nos propres
patients et ils en sont conscients et
après le besoin de formation du
personnel le moins qualifiés est
extrêmement important et si on regarde
les budgets de formation sont ils
correctement à louer on s'il priorités
ont été priorisés sur des personnels qui
ont une forte valeur ajoutée dans les
eaux dans les hôpitaux dans les ehpad et
même dans le monde libéral
c'est une vraie question je pense que on
manque d'investissements pour rendre
attractif les métiers les plus
difficiles de l'hôpital le paiement
c'est une chose la formation c'est une
chose la qualité delà du niveau de
formation de nausées des dosettes
soignants de nous regardiez on a
aujourd'hui on a tellement besoin de
main d'oeuvre que l'on accepte des
personnes qui dont on pourrait se poser
la question de savoir si leur place est
encore dans le personnel soignant si
elle refuse de se vacciner c'est très
clairement la question qui se pose est à
brno megaman en tout cas d'académie ne
fait pas de distinction elle parle de
vraiment de tous les soignants
on sait que royaume uni c'est
obligatoire pour les pour les personnels
on n'est pas uniquement ça pose quand
même une question sur les libertés
individuelles de force et de contraindre
les gens à se faire vacciner est ce
qu'il faut aller à défaut de pédagogie
en tout cas si la pédagogie
ne vais pas ne marche pas jusqu'au bout
est-ce qu'il faudra la rendre
obligatoire et ça pose pas une question
de liberté individuelle alors j'allais
dire autant ça peut le poser à l'échelle
de la population générale je vous
rappelle que la capd et l'académie de
médecine a même recommandé la
vaccination obligatoire pour l'ensemble
des adultes
par contre pour un soignant je crois là
il ya des devoirs
on a choisi d'être soignant il y à un
certain nombre de devoirs qui nous
incombe
et si on ne souhaite pas les remplir on
n'a qu'à sortir du système de soins est
allé faire un autre travail
je crois que la première le premier
devoir d'un soignant et de ne pas
aggraver la situation de son patient et
de se donner le maximum des moyens pour
améliorer sa situation
malheureusement dans beaucoup de cas
nous sommes démunis car la médecine est
incapable de soigner toutes les maladies
c'est pas pour autant évidemment qu'il
faut de nuire aux patients que l'on a
entre les mains
donc je crois que la vaccination contre
la coved effectivement s'impose à nous
tous je crois on peut encore donner
quelques jours ou semaines pour
convaincre et pour laisser le temps car
je suis d'accord un certain nombre de
personnes qui ont peut-être été
infectées au cours de cette dernière
vague attendent encore les trois mois
nécessaires pour se faire vacciner
mais passé un certain délai je crois
qu'il faudra rendre les choses
obligatoire pour éviter à nouveau une
catastrophe dans les ehpad et les
hôpitaux en septembre-octobre et
bertrand il ya aussi la question de la
strazeele et cas on se souvient qu'au
départ on voulait à vacciner les
soignants avec ce sérum qui n'a pas eu
toujours bonne presse et on entendait
moi je n'ai entendu certains médecins
j'ai pas envie d'être deux jours voilà
avec 40 de fièvre lit avec ses effets
secondaires qui étaient parfois connu
pour astrazeneca est ce que les choses
peuvent évoluer de ce point de vue là si
on choisit un autre vaccin pour ces
soignants
aujourd'hui les soignants sont très
majoritairement des personnes de moins
de 55 ans tout s'est heureusement ça n'a
pas beaucoup changé
et du coup elles ne sont pas éligibles à
l'astra zeneca ou janssen elles ne sont
éligibles comme moderna ou au kaiser
donc tu as de ce problème là il est
réglé à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
après personnellement je me suis vacciné
à l'astra je vais très bien et je suis
toujours vivant comme vous pouvez le
voir il ya pas de problème crème la
majorité de mes collègues et confrères
qui se sont vaccinés à l'astra bien sûr
vieux on a eu un peu de fièvre bon on a
été travaillé quand même hein c'est pas
dramatique
bruno mégaphone c'est un bon signal
quand même ça pose question quel message
envoyé aux antilles vax quand on voit
que beaucoup de soignants ne veulent pas
se faire vacciner
est ce qu'on connaît leurs vraies
motivations profondes ce qui a une
méfiance envers le vaccin alors je pense
que la majorité des personnes soignantes
qui ne se sont pas encore fait vacciner
sont en fait plutôt dans la tente que
vraiment dans la méfiance complète
vis-à-vis du vaccin
à mon sens une très grosse partie de ces
personnes vont se faire vacciner
évidemment il persistera une infime
minorité de personnes vaccinaux
sceptiques voire militant contre la
vaccination mais ça reste vraiment une
infime minorité à la marge il faut
rappeler qu effectivement à partir de
septembre octobre le virus var circuler
et c'est d'ailleurs essentiellement les
souches les plus contagieuses voire
peut-être si de nouvelles souches
apparaissez dé souche plus virulente qui
vont circuler
or nous tous allons évidemment adopter
un mode de vie quasi normale car la très
grosse majorité des adultes sera vacciné
les lieux d'interactions sociales les
restaurants les cafés les bars sont
ouverts or les personnes non vaccinées
devront en alternative mettre
systématiquement le masque partout et
conserver la distanciation sociale
malheureusement il ne
le ferons pas car évidemment ils
adopteront le mode de vie de ceux qui
les entourent
c'est à dire des personnes vaccinées il
courant le risque d'être contaminé et de
venir à l'hôpital et de surcharger les
services d urgence et de réanimation et
malheureusement de décéder il faut
rappeler à nouveau la vaccination et
d'avant avant toute chose une protection
individuelle de la personne qui se fait
vacciner
en tout cas il ya beaucoup de colère
chez les personnels soignants pas
forcément que dans les ehpad je vous
propose d'écouter cette réaction du
collectif inter blocks faire sur les
réseaux sociaux
la vaccination est un moyen mais pas le
seul
à quand l'application de l'obligation de
protection maximale envers les soignants
avec des masques ffp2 2 qualité et
sécurité maximale et non des cas n 95
chinois non conformes ou avec des
produits toxiques
on est sept cette colère et ses
questionnements bertrand legrand
oui quand on en avait besoin on a eu les
certains sont restés sur 7 sur cette
notion m'ont fait bien en fait d un
moment donné où s'opposer tout le temps
c'est très bien mais il ya un moment où
il faut quand même regarder les choses
aujourd'hui on a plus de problème de
masquer ce serait complètement faux de
dire qu'on n'a pas de masque à
disposition et d'ailleurs je me demande
bien encore pourquoi on et remboursent
etc etc
il ya un moment donné où effectivement
on est majoritaire à être vaccinés la
majorité des bd français valette maxime
et la majorité des français ont fait les
efforts qu'il fallait pour préserver la
génération du dessus combien de temps
encore on va faire des efforts
financiers pour des gens qui refusent la
vaccination un moment donné ces gens
doivent être responsables de ce qu'ils
font et la responsabilité quand on ne se
vaccinent pas c'est évidemment qu'on ne
travaille pas dans un milieu à risque la
deuxième responsabilité c'est qu'on
prend en charge ses propres soins et je
les invite donc à réfléchir aussi à tout
ce qu'ils font peser sur la france par
serge moment donné on peut pas demander
la liberté et ne pas assumer ses devoirs
et des choses qui incombe à la liberté
merci beaucoup vous nommez gardanne et
bertrand legrand d'avoir été avec nous
parce que ça fasse ce soir merci à vous